hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
before we get started I want to mention
the giveaway that I'm doing there's only
about two days left before the winner is
announced so if you haven't put your
entries in yet you only have a few days
left to do so I'm giving away the
complete Game of Thrones series on
blu-ray to one of you that have entered
and if you haven't yet just go down to
the link down in the description where
there are multiple ways you can submit
an entry which will give you more
chances to try to win this series I want
to thank those of you that have
participated this is something I wanted
to give back for supporting me in the
videos that I make which I truly do
appreciate so good luck to everyone and
there's one more thing I want to mention
I will be doing a few different collab
videos this weekend with the channel
smokescreen and we've been kicking
around a few different ideas trying to
decide what we wanted to record and put
out to you guys so we may do a Q&A type
video for one of these recordings so if
you guys want if you have any questions
pertaining to the future seasons like
season 7 and season 8 leave some Q&A
questions down at the bottom of this
video and when I record with smokescreen
this weekend we'll try to get to as many
of those Q&A questions as we can but
like I said just try to make them season
7 and season 8 related so we can give
you our future prediction and theories
so thank you guys and let's get things
started we die today brothers we die
bleeding for the hollered wound without
all in our necks and spin and out good
but our war cries will echo through
eternity they will sing about the Battle
of Winterfell until the Iron Islands
have slipped beneath the waves every man
woman and child will know who we were
and how long we stood ironborn warriors
will cry out our names as they leap onto
the shores of seagard Vergara
those who name their son for us girls
will think of us with their lovers
ignitor
I don't wanna tell that [ __ ] old
flower that in from above the shores of
Pyke was this dead blade ever guy today
I want to talk about Theon Greyjoy in
his story arc and some of the things I
think he can do in order to redeem
himself and possibly even be remembered
as a hero but this is going to be an
easy thing to do considering the road
Phelan has been on but I will briefly
start from the beginning and work my way
up to fianc potential New Found Glory
Phelan was once hostage in ward of Ned
Stark but he ended up becoming almost a
part of the family there was even a time
that Phelan said Ned Stark was like a
second father to him and although Theon
would never be a stark by blood Robb
Stark was like a brother to him lady
Catelyn even showed Theon more respect
than she did John Snow who was related
to her children and husband by blood
vielen did pretty much everything with
the Starks he didn't live like a typical
hostage award would but as much love
that feelin ended up having for the
Starks there came a point to where he
grew tired of being looked down upon by
others that he came in contact with
throughout the first season every time
someone made a remark to Theon about his
living situation you could see the wheel
slowly starting to turn inside his head
he wanted some respect and he also
wanted to be loved by his true father
like any son would which is completely
understandable but a few miscalculations
led Theon down a dark path during his
quest for this respect and power that he
so eagerly wanted there was a key moment
that took place in the beginning of the
story that set the tone for the rest of
the series and could potentially play a
big role in feelin's future this is when
Jaime Lannister pushes bran Stark from
the window of the tower at Winterfell
and I got to be honest guys I was very
surprised the first time I saw this I
was not expecting one of the main
characters to attempt to murder a child
who was another main character in the
very first episode of this series but
luckily bran survives
although crippled but he did not
remember how he fell but thanks to Lady
Columbo she discovered exactly who was
responsible for this after she had found
a golden hair in that
our knowing that no one had been up
there but now there are a few golden
haired sickos within winner fells walls
that haven't had the best reputation
lady Catelyn then held a secret meeting
into God's woods revealing her findings
in a tower and who she suspected was
responsible for brands injury but almost
everyone who was at that meeting is now
dead except for Theon Greyjoy and if
there are anyone else out there who
knows Jamie Lannister did this they
aren't going to have the same motivation
to alert the starch like feelings can
have but we're going to come back to
this part later after Lord Eddard Stark
is executed Robb Stark is proclaimed
king in the north by his bannermen see
on Dennis Robb if they are brothers now
and always
and after Rob says yes they are brothers
Theon then swears his sword in fealty to
rob but things are about to take a turn
for the worse when Phelan suggests to
rob that they should seek an alliance
with Theon's father Balon Greyjoy
because they will need a fleet of ships
to attack King's Landing
then which Robb agrees to so he sends
Theon home to broker a deal with his
father that he hasn't seen since he was
just a boy but beyonds welcomed home
wasn't as warm as he had thought it
would have been Zealand's appearance
alone angers his father he is dressed
like a stark wearing abercrombie and
fitch that he did not pay the iron price
for and Balin rejects Rob's offer he
doesn't want anyone to hand him a thing
he reminds t on that they pay the iron
price and take what they want and this
is the beginning of feelin's downfall he
makes a decision that he knows he
shouldn't have made but deep down he
knows he is Ironborn and he wants to
respect from the men and only wants to
be loved and thought of as a man by his
father which I can't blame the guy but
he made a critical mistake in doing so
when he decided to attack Winterfell and
hold everyone their prisoner then he
forces bran Stark to yield to him which
was a decision that should have cost him
his life but as we all know something
much worse end up happening to Theon
Ceylon ends up a prisoner of Ramsay
Bolton's and is brutally tortured for
years and even though I was angry at him
for what he did at Winterfell the
torture was so much that I wanted it to
stop I want
Ramzi to show him some mercy whether
that be stopping the torture altogether
or putting Thielen out of his misery
either way no man should be tortured
like that and for that long but then
Sansa shows up and it's pretty much left
with no choice but to marry Ramsay
Bolton who ended up beating and raping
her as well even forcing Theon to watch
at times but eventually Songza gained
the strength and courage to try to
escape the clutch of Ramsay Bolton even
though she knew if she had been caught
it would have only made things much much
worse and I think if it wasn't for Shaun
- repeating ly reminding Theon of who he
was he may have never left Ramsay he was
too scared and broken to even attempt to
escape on his own at this point
Theon or reek had accepted their fate
and dealt with it any way that he could
but thanks to Sansa she put things in
motion that are not only going to change
Dion's life but also how he will be
remembered even after he has gone Sansa
had set the plan in motion she had
decided that she was escaping one way or
another but Ramsay sidepiece Miranda
knew exactly what she was up to and
stopped saans a dead in her tracks by
holding a bow and arrow at point-blank
range to her face and this is the
beginning of a new day this is the
beginning of the rise of feel--and
Greyjoy ladies and gentlemen Siwon knew
he had to act fast because the Bolton
men were coming back so he tossed that
[ __ ] over the wall where she fell to
her death then him and Songz had jumped
over the wall not knowing if they would
even survive the landing from that
height but it wasn't long and the Bolton
men ran them down and I got to be honest
people
what fian did next was pretty damn brave
he stepped out in front of the Bolton
men and their hounds he was ready to
give himself up so that songs that could
escape knowing that if he was taken back
to Ramsay he may have been brutally
tortured for god knows how long or even
killed
so I tipped my head to you for that one
feeling that took balls balls that you
no longer have but you had the guts to
find anyway luckily for the both of them
Brienne and Podrick showed up and with
all of them combined they were able to
kill all of the Bolton men Theon even
killed one of the men which makes this
the second time Theon has killed someone
in order to save a Starks life he saved
ran when he was wandering off and ran
into OSHA in the men's she was with and
then he helped another Starks life right
here so as you can see Phelan started
out basically one of the Starks family
members then he ended up deserting Rob
when he needed him the most and after
living with that guilt for all these
years he finally had a chance to redeem
himself here and save the lady of
Winterfell but beyond is not done yet
his character has much more to give to
this story and there are other things
that I can see him doing to take his
character from tortured coward to
respected hero which I will explain if
Theon does end up dying he's going to
die doing something very important but
at this point I can actually see him
surviving the entire series think about
it if they were going to kill Phelan
they would have already they invested so
much time showing us Theon being
tortured so why not just put him out of
his misery then why continue to show us
this character being tortured day in and
day out episode after episode they kept
him alive because he has a bigger role
to play they needed Theon to save lady
Sansa
what she did and if he was going to kill
his character then why did you not kill
him after he helps on to escape it
seemed like his character was fulfilling
his purpose at that point so why
continue to let him live unless you have
something bigger in store for him it
would be stupid to kill him now unless
it's doing something very important or
else they wouldn't have kept him alive
for so long when he should have died so
many times already at first I thought
they were keeping him alive so that he
could become king of the Iron Islands
but then Euron shows up and takes
control of the islands which forced the
on in Yara to escape or else they would
have been killed there and now fian has
the backing of one of if not the most
powerful characters in the series
Daenerys Targaryen she definitely has
the biggest force which now feeling is a
part of so you can see that he still has
a role to play and I think I know what
this is but I must warn you spoilers are
coming we know from the spoilers that
Danny's fleet is going to take a
significant hit at the beginning of next
season
Euron eventually catches up to them and
apparently takes out Yara's Ironborn
fleet which results in Euron actually
capturing yara but beyond narrowly
escapes
avoids death once again and other
spoiler photos have came out that show
your ax as a prisoner of your own
Greyjoy's and in those photos you can
see you're on as Jorah chained up behind
this horse as he parades her through
King's Landing more than likely on his
way to Cersei Lannister so at this point
Yara is pretty screwed there are other
spoiler photos that show Theon getting
his ass kicked by the Ironborn more than
likely because Yara was taken prisoner
and for all they know possibly even
killed then in other photos we see seen
on having an altercation with Jon Snow
on the beach at Dragonstone this is the
first time these characters have seen
each other in a very long time and even
when they were living under the same
roof
Theon didn't show Jon the respect he
should have but that means nothing at
this point because John is going to be
furious at him for turning his back on
Robb and holding Winterfell hostage
which resulted in a few people dying but
Jon isn't going to kill him and that's
only because Thielen saved saw his life
but that doesn't mean the Starks have to
welcome him back with open arms but now
that Filan is under Danny's wing they're
going to have to learn how to work
together and I think Theon is going to
attempt to save his sister's life
just like she tried to rescue him when
he was Ramsay's prisoner vielen is going
to take his beating but he's going to
step up and do what he knows he has to
do and take his uncle you're on on face
to face Ceylon will have to muster up
the strength and courage to lead the
Ironborn men in an attempt to get his
sister back knowing it could cost him
his life Joran is a seasoned veteran on
the sea and not only that he has Yara in
King's Landing which is littered with
city watch not to mention if Cersei ends
up having Yara under her thumb
that means she will more than likely be
guarded by Kingsguard and that damn
mountain which makes it nearly
impossible for a man like Theon to stay
in a chance of getting her back but I
think he will put his life on the line
during an attempt to rescue his sister
Yara if he wants any respect from anyone
he cannot let his sister rot in King's
Landing and more than likely be tortured
and killed c1 may end up coming face to
face with your on which one of them will
end up dying but I want to go back to
the godswood when lady Catelyn held her
secret meeting in revealed who was
responsible for brains injury
now that feelin is a free man and able
to speak on his own this gives him the
perfect opportunity to reveal this
information to the Starks John
especially now that he's going to meet
John on the beach and John's going to
grab him by the neck on the beach at
Dragonstone this would be the perfect
time to tell John what lady Catelyn had
told him about Jamie and Cersei being
the reason that brain is now crippled
and I wouldn't be surprised if feeling
offered to help making sure that Jamie
faces justice when the opportunity
presents itself Phelan was very vocal
about his feelings toward Jamie when
lady Catelyn said he was responsible for
Brants injury
Theon knew Jamie was absolutely capable
of doing this in the first novel Sir
Roderick said even the Kingslayer would
flinch at the murder of an innocent
child
but Fenelon said Oh would he I wonder
Theon knew that Jamie was capable and
likely the culprit when vielen fought
beside Robb at the Battle of the
whispering wood this is when they were
able to take Jaime prisoner
Theon wanted to kill Jamie and send his
head back to Tywin to send a message but
Robb refused so it's obvious that
feeling hates Jaime and he knows he is
responsible for brans injury so now that
he will be around the Starks again I can
see him not only revealing this
information but wanting to help also
when Jaime push spraying out the window
that was a pivotal moment in this series
so there was no way this doesn't get
resolved in some form or fashion
Theon didn't survive all this time and
survived all that torture and horror
just so they could randomly kill him off
I believe he is still around to serve a
bigger purpose than what he has been
doing
I think attempting to save Yara and
telling everyone what he knows about
Jaime Lannister can be some of the
things they can have him do to continue
to rise and complete his story arc but
these are just my opinions of course so
comment below and tell me what you think
Theon will be doing in the upcoming
episodes he has survived so much what
purpose do you see him having in the
future let me know and I will see you
guys down in the comments thanks for
watching thanks for supporting the
videos in the channel I will see you
guys in the next one bye